JEFF POSNICK: Hey, everybody.
This is Jeff Posnick with this
week's episode of "YouTube
Developers Live." And we're
coming to you from New York
City and we have a
special guest in
town for today's episode.
It's John Luther, who's the
product manager behind WebM
and VP8 and all sorts of
other video goodness.
So welcome, John.
JOHN LUTHER: Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Good morning.
Good night.
Good evening, wherever
you happen to be.
JEFF POSNICK: That's the beauty
of global audience.
JOHN LUTHER: That's
the web, right?
JEFF POSNICK: So you don't know
where you are and when
you're watching.
JOHN LUTHER: Or who's
watching.
JEFF POSNICK: Exactly.
Cool.
So before we get started,
there's a lot of acronyms
involved and there's a lot of
specific technical language
that's used when talking about
video codecs and video file
formats, and not everybody might
be familiar with them.
So as not to lose everybody
from the very start of the
show, maybe we could just go
through some basics to begin
with so folks know what
we're talking about.
JOHN LUTHER: Sure.
JEFF POSNICK: So the phrases
video container, video codec,
and audio codec seem pretty
important to me.
JOHN LUTHER: Yes.
JEFF POSNICK: And maybe you
could go into a little bit
more about what they all do.
JOHN LUTHER: It's funny you
should mention that because I
happen to have a graphic
for this.
JEFF POSNICK: I would love to
see the graphic, if we could
bring that up on the screen.
So there we go.
JOHN LUTHER: So when we talk
about video for the web, which
is our focus, I mean,
the WebM project is
named that for a reason.
Our primary focus is on
video for the web.
We're not necessarily interested
in broadcast
television, anything
like that.
So for web video in most cases
what you have is a container,
which is the file that
contains the media.
So here I've kind of just laid
out all the steps of creating
a video file.
There's roughly the same for a
live stream, but just for that
sake of simplicity
I made this.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So you start with
your application, which can be
a camera, a video editing
software, wherever the media
is originating from.
And that will export raw media,
video, and audio streams.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So then what we
do, like in the case of
YouTube, we put those streams
into VP8 video encoder and a
Vorbis audio coder.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So the VP8 video
codec is what Google acquired
from On2 Technologies and what
we've been working on for the
past, now, almost three years.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: Vorbis is an open
source audio format that was
developed by the Xiph
Foundation, Monty, Montgomery,
Tim Terriberry, those guys,
if people are familiar.
They're also the same guys
who are now working
on Opus audio codec.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So when those
streams get encoded they get
compressed.
So the goal of all this is to
take these raw streams, which
are very, very big, lots of
data, raw pixels, and compress
that down into a stream that's
usable across the internet--
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: --you
know, megabit
connection, 2 megabits.
So those are then muxed,
multiplexed--
JEFF POSNICK: Yes.
JOHN LUTHER: --into a container
file, which
is your WebM file.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So within that you
can have multiple video
streams, multiple
audio streams.
In most cases you have
one audio, one video.
And then that's what you sort
of put on your server.
MIME type is WebM, so just like
a JPEG file contains a
stream for the still image,
a Word document contains a
stream of English or French.
You kind of think of
it that way,--
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: --just a
way to wrap it all
up in a nice package.
And then when the client, the
web browser, the video tag in
HTML, then demuxes that,
demultiplexes, it takes the
video stream into the video
decoder, audio stream into the
audio decoder, and then, through
the media pipeline and
the browser, renders it all
through the screen.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool, OK.
JOHN LUTHER: That's how
the magic happens.
That's the very, very minimal
description of what goes on.
JEFF POSNICK: Fair enough.
So if you hear VP8, we're
talking about the video codec.
JOHN LUTHER: Correct.
JEFF POSNICK: And if you hear
WebM, we're talking about the
overall video file format
containing the muxed streams.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
Hopefully that answers
some questions.
And one takeaway from the show,
if nothing else, people
will understand video file
formats a little bit better.
JOHN LUTHER: Exactly.
JEFF POSNICK: Awesome.
OK, so now that we know what
we're talking about, let's get
into a little bit of the details
as to why somebody
would actually want to use WebM
and VP8 versus some of
the other [INAUDIBLE] and codecs
that are out there.
What are some advantages?
JOHN LUTHER: Well, one of the
advantages of VP8 is that it's
a very, very efficient codec.
I mean, it was developed roughly
2009-ish and then we
acquired it in 2010.
JEFF POSNICK: I was expecting
you to say 2,000 years ago.
JOHN LUTHER: No, no.
JEFF POSNICK: This is a
very ancient codec.
JOHN LUTHER: [INAUDIBLE]
business that long,
but not that long.
JEFF POSNICK: Lots of papyrus,
hardware acceleration, stuff
like that, but--
JOHN LUTHER: We were drawing the
pixels by hand back when I
first started.
JEFF POSNICK: Yes.
JOHN LUTHER: No.
So you know, it's a modern
codec, as the parlance goes in
the industry.
It's very, very efficient.
The quality that it delivers
is great, HD as well as
smaller frame sizes.
But also, one of the advantages
of VP8 is that it's
a very low latency codec.
JEFF POSNICK: OK, why
does that matter?
JOHN LUTHER: Real-time
applications.
For example, one of the things
that VP8 is proposed for now
is the WebRTC project, which
is an open source real-time
media project, for example, for
making video conferencing
applications in the browser.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: Those
sorts of things.
So at the IETF standards
organization, VP8 has been
proposed as a mandatory codec
for that use case.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So what we can do
is with VP8, because the
latency is so small, you can
have these very good video
conferencing applications
where there's no delay.
Even if the network gets kind
of funky, starts dropping
packets, and all sorts of crazy
stuff happens, we can
recover from errors.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: Lot
of that stuff.
So we've designed it to be a
very good all around codec.
But as part of that we wanted
it to be one codec.
We didn't want profiles
and levels.
And there's a lot of
other codecs--
not necessarily that it's all
bad, but we wanted the design
to be very simple and serve
every use case without having
to have special decoders.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So other codecs,
you know when you hear about a
profile in, for example, H.264
baseline profile, they're
actually different codecs.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: A baseline decoder
can't decode a high
profile 264 stream.
VP8 is VP8.
A VP8 stream created from a
compliant encoder will play
and decode in any VP8 decoder.
So there's simplicity of design,
there's efficiency.
We don't charge any money
for it, which a
lot of people like.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: Other codecs
have royalties
associated with them.
We don't charge for VP8.
It's a very wide open license.
It's a BSD open-source
license.
There are people out there
using it who aren't even
calling it VP8 and they have
every right to do that.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: That's [INAUDIBLE]
the license allows.
So that's--
you know, overall
high-efficiency and
simplicity of design.
And decoding simplicity goes
with that as well.
I mean, we can decode VP8 on
pretty minimal hardware
[INAUDIBLE] in software.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah.
JEFF POSNICK: That sounds
pretty compelling.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah.
JEFF POSNICK: Good to know.
OK, so that's a little
bit about VP8.
You mentioned the fact that VP8
kind of initially started
as part of a separate company,
On2, that Google acquired.
Can I just hear a little bit
about your history and your
involvement with the
overall project?
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah.
JEFF POSNICK: [INAUDIBLE]
with video working with.
JOHN LUTHER: Let's see.
Well, On2 started as a couple
of people from New York City
and a school in upstate New
York called Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute.
So they started this company
to initially do video in
gaming systems like the Sega
Saturn and all things--
JEFF POSNICK: That creates
it a little bit.
JOHN LUTHER: You young people
out there, you might--
so that was '93, '94.
I came along in 2002.
By then-- when it started it was
called Duck Corporation,
just being silly.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: It became On2.
2002 is when I joined.
And then we developed a series
of, you know, the VP3 series,
VP4, all the way up to VP7.
And then we released
VP8 in 2009.
Google acquired us in 2010.
So I've been doing this
now for 11 years.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: Which--
you know, there are more and
more people who have been
doing it that long, but I feel
like I have a lot of
perspective on this stuff.
And it takes a long time.
And a lot of people have said,
or implied, that VP8 hasn't
caught on, but this is pretty
much about when the curve
starts to come.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: I mean, I remember
when H.264 was first
ratified as a standard,
that was early 2000s.
It really didn't come into
its own, at least
for the web, until--
really the iPad is what really
then sort of got everybody
wanting to support it
and everything else.
So I'm very bullish on VP8 for
the next many years, because
there's hardware coming
to market.
We can get into all
that stuff--
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: For me, that's
my [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
Well, I mean it's wonderful
having somebody with your
perspective on the show
to talk about this.
JOHN LUTHER: Thanks.
JEFF POSNICK: All right, so
let's say I'm just your
average YouTube consumer.
Like everybody out there, like
everybody who's watching us
right now, I like watching
YouTube videos.
But I'm not necessarily a
developer, and I'm not maybe
creating videos.
So what does WebM mean for me?
Why should I care about WebM?
JOHN LUTHER: Just for your
everyday user they don't
really need to care.
Or at least, we don't want them
to care in the sense that
like, well, I only want to have
this-- all they want is a
really good video experience.
They want it to look good, same
priorities that we have,
but they're going to
frame them in terms
of watching a video.
So it should start fast, it
should seek without a lot of
weird stuttering.
The audio, video should
never go out.
You know, just very good viewing
experience that is
seamless, that's what
they care about.
And we feel like that's sort of
the focus of our project.
That's what we're doing.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: And our, sort of,
charter, if you will, is to
make video on the web
really great.
Part of that's the codec,
but there's other
parts of it as well.
I also work with Chrome, the
browser, the video stack in
there, making that a really
great experience.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: Other WebM partners
like Firefox, we're
all kind of on this mission,
if you will, to take the
technologies that we're
developing and make them great
on the web.
Because historically a lot of
the codecs that have been used
for web video were not designed
for the web, they
were designed for broadcast
television or use cases.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So, yeah.
I mean, we certainly don't want
people to have to feel
like they have to
know essentially
how the codec works.
We don't really want people
to have to know that.
We just want them to be like,
oh, wow, this video looks
great, it works great,
I wonder what it---
why?
And then you say, well, that's
because it's VP8.
JEFF POSNICK: Gotchya.
JOHN LUTHER: We care
about these things.
So that's why we do it.
JEFF POSNICK: And just for some
background on how YouTube
is using WebM in embeds, we have
a very extensible iFrame
Embed format now.
And one of the things about the
iFrame Embed is that it'll
kind of try to push the logic
of the video player and the
video format to Run-time and not
have to hard code a flash
player, URL, or anything
like that.
So if you are somebody who's
watching a video and it
happens to be embedded with the
iFrame Embed, there's a
good chance that you might be
watching HTML5 video using the
WebM video format
and not know it.
So again, I think
this really--
not necessarily knowing
it, but you might
already be doing that.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah.
JEFF POSNICK: And, you know, you
might be benefiting from
all those things
that it offers.
So it is definitely relevant
for folks like those.
JOHN LUTHER: And there are cases
where as soon as you're
not using it you might notice.
For example, like I for a while
had a machine that--
a computer that I won't
name [INAUDIBLE].
And every time I would be
playing video from YouTube and
H.264 the fan would start
running, whereas because one
of our design goals is low
complexity on the decode side,
it just never happened on
that machine when I was
using HTML5 with WebM.
So those sorts of things
start to matter
when you notice them.
We don't want anybody to ever
have to notice any of that
stuff, just it works great and
we're doing the big work to
make video on the web great.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
OK.
Yeah, one kind of scenario that
we haven't really talked
about publicly yet but I'm told
it's OK that we mention
it here is that what about
people who want to watch some
of the types of premium YouTube
content on a device
that doesn't support flash?
And how does WebM come into
the picture on that?
JOHN LUTHER: So this
is pretty exciting.
Last month we rolled out the
Samsung Chromebook devices
that were released last fall,
which have been in very high
demand on Amazon
and elsewhere.
So what we did is we decided
to make that
sort of an HTML5 platform.
That's where we really thought
there was a great case to do
more HTML5 stuff.
So what we did on YouTube Movies
and Play Movies is on
those devices, Samsung
Chromebooks, if you buy or
rent a movie on YouTube Movies
or Play, that's a WebM
experience, that plays WebM.
JEFF POSNICK: And previously
you had to do that in flash
player, or--
JOHN LUTHER: Previously you'd
have to have Flash Player.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So as far
as I know we're the
first to ever do that.
Because it also uses some things
that we've proposed at
W3C for doing encrypted media
in the browser, media source
extensions for HTML, so there's
a dash-like adaptive
streaming going on.
There's a whole bunch of
things and we said
OK, let's do this.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: Let's
do it all, end to
end, HTML5, the browser.
There's no flash.
There's no plug-ins.
There's no anything.
That whole experience on that
device is all HTML.
And we'll be rolling that out on
more Chromeless devices and
other platforms soon, all
through the next year.
JEFF POSNICK: And then, again,
this kind of fits into like if
you're someone viewing, you
might not realize what's going
on under the hood.
But hopefully for the technical
audience out there,
folks watching this,
it's pretty cool.
It's exciting for
me, certainly.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah.
It's exciting, you know--
JEFF POSNICK: If you care about
these types of standards
on the web and getting this type
of playback on more types
of devices, it's very cool.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah,
that is part of--
my job is doing the encrypted
media stuff and talking to
people who want to do--
a lot of content providers they
really want to do HTML5
for a number of reasons.
But primarily because right now
they have an app for this
device, and an app for that
device, and this game console
and they want to just unify all
that into a browser stack,
so s I feel like
that's coming.
And that's really exciting
because finally they'll be
able to just deliver
one experience
any device, any screen.
Under the covers it will
all work the same way.
It makes it really great for
users, first of all, but for
them as well it just simplifies
things greatly for
those guys.
JEFF POSNICK: OK, cool.
So we talked a little bit about
the experience of people
who are watching content.
What if you were a
website owner?
And I talked a little bit before
about using the iFrame
Embed for YouTube for enabling
types of rich playback, but
exactly how widespread is WebM
support in the browser
community out there?
What's the chance that folks
visiting your site will have
WebM support in their browser?
JOHN LUTHER: The last numbers
that I ran were a few days ago
and so the native support in the
browser, like WebM is in
there, it's in the video tag,
that's now at about 57% when
you combine Chrome, Firefox,
and the Opera browser.
Now, there's also plug-ins
that you can install for
Internet Explorer
to support WebM.
If you then add that on that's
an addressable market--
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: --of about
another 17%.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So the chances
are pretty good, and
particularly with Chrome
and Firefox.
And the performance in
both is very good.
Since we launched it we've made
a lot of refinements.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
That's good to hear.
So--
JOHN LUTHER: Oh, I should
mention Android as well.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: Ever since
Gingerbread, WebM has been
supported in Android.
JEFF POSNICK: It's a pretty
big platform.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah, I guess
it is, isn't it?
A few hundred, whatever,
bazillion people.
JEFF POSNICK: There you go.
Don't quote us on that.
JOHN LUTHER: No, that's not
a scientific figure.
Bazillion I don't think is
a real number anyway.
JEFF POSNICK: There you go.
OK, so that's the website
owner point of view.
Let's say a slightly different
scenario, I'm
somebody who's a developer.
Maybe I'm working on a video
creation application, or maybe
I'm just interested in ways of
encoding video for use in my
application because I'm
not doing necessarily
browser-based playback, but I
know I want to have video
playback or even video capture
within my application.
What could WebM do for me?
And do you maybe have some
examples of how you could
interact with WebM
in that case?
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah, I mean this
is one of the great things
about the web and being a
developer is that it depends a
lot on what you want to do
and what your needs are.
If you have a small site and you
do a couple videos a week
you can encode them on your
local desktop with--
there's a lot of tools now
that support WebM.
But let's say you have a higher
volume site where you
may be getting dozens or
hundreds of videos a week,
there are a lot of really
great cloud-based video
encoding services now where they
have really great APIs.
Most of them are kind
of REST-based.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: You send a file
in and then they give you a
pointer back to encoder
version.
It's very fast.
They have really good presets.
They take care of a lot of
the tweaking for you.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
And YouTube does support WebM as
an injection for that also.
JOHN LUTHER: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
JEFF POSNICK: So once you have
your WebM encoded file you
could pass that along to
YouTube, obviously, and store
it there and serve it there.
JOHN LUTHER: I mean, there's
companies that are doing that
even behind the scenes.
Some gaming companies and things
are doing that as well.
So then it becomes,
for a developer--
it's like a lot of things.
You want to focus on the user
experience of the site, making
it work great, reliability,
encoding the videos.
You can do that stuff
in the cloud now.
And it's becoming so much easier
and you don't need a
huge investment in a
lot of hardware.
Because encoding video--
it's not just VP8, all
video is very compute
intensive to do.
It's just sort of the
nature of the thing.
JEFF POSNICK: That being said,
let's say you are somebody who
wants to do on-device video
encoding, maybe because you're
capturing, game play as part
of a game or something like
that and you want to do the
encoding and then pass it
along to YouTube.
JOHN LUTHER: So, yeah, the SDK
that we have is called libvpx.
It's open, it's up on
the site, anything.
Right now that's sort of
mostly the C interface.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: We've recently made
some J and I bindings for
that so you can, right in Java,
talk to that SDK through
Java interfaces.
And one of the things that we'd
like the open community
to do is develop more of those
bindings for other--
because of the nature of
websites and things, not
everybody's out there
hacking in C--
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: --and C++.
So Python bindings, and PHP, and
Pearl, or C#, we'd like to
have language bindings to make
this stuff easy for anybody to
just take the SDK and write any
kind of app they want and
have the languages and
interfaces that they're
familiar with, not a steep
learning curve.
And it's sort of like the sky's
the limit for what you
can do with that SDK.
And then again, we don't
charge money for it.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: Anybody
can use it.
Not only use it, but if they
find a bug or improve it then
just send those changes
upstream and we're
happy to take them.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
So let's say I do want to go
out there and find some
resources for how I
could get started
with doing some encoding.
I assume there is a canonical
website that
folks should go to.
JOHN LUTHER: There is.
JEFF POSNICK: So maybe we can
pull that up on the screen.
JOHN LUTHER: This is the
WebM project site.
It's everything you need to know
about WebM, VP8, also the
experimental codec
work we're doing.
It's all here.
JEFF POSNICK: And it's
webmproject.org?
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah.
So developers, this is sort of
more software developers and
web developers as well, but this
is more for maybe people
who want to contribute
to the codec.
The tools section is I think
where this audience might find
a lot of useful stuff.
There's a lot of open source
tools that support WebM now.
JEFF POSNICK: It seems like
FFmpeg might be the entry
point that a lot
of people use.
JOHN LUTHER: Yup.
And FFmpeg has been really
great for WebM because it
underlies so much software now
for doing video processing.
Not only open-source stuff, but
a lot of the cloud-based
services, a lot of video sites
use it behind the scenes now.
So these are just some of the
commercial tools, the
cloud-based things.
So if you did want to get
adventurous and start using
FFmpeg to create WebM files,
what I've done here-- this is
just a very simple and quick
demo of how you would do that.
So let's find like this one.
So this is just a pretty simple
command to create a
WebM file from a .MoveFile I
have that is a H.264 file.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So what
this is doing
is the quality settings--
there's sort of different
modes in VP8 for
encoding the video.
There's real-time, good, best.
Good is in most cases, even
though it's a little bit
non-intuitive, good is
usually what you want
because it's faster.
Best is designed for squeezing
the absolute best out of it,
but it's going to take a
lot more processing.
JEFF POSNICK: Maybe create an
[INAUDIBLE] that's like really
good just to let people know
that this is really good.
And best like--
JOHN LUTHER: Best is--
JEFF POSNICK: --a little insane,
a little too much.
JOHN LUTHER: It should
be, like, wait a long
time, not so long.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
JOHN LUTHER: But for most use
cases, especially for web
video, the good setting is
usually where you want to be.
You can control in the encoder
how much CPU the encode takes.
You can set a lower priority
if you want.
It'll take longer, but if you
want to then be doing other
stuff on that machine--
JEFF POSNICK: For instance, if
you are including this as part
of a game or some sort of
application where you're
capturing video and
then encoding it.
That [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah, that's
a perfect example.
In gameplay you would want to be
setting this to real-time.
Because whether you're writing
it to disc or sending it up to
YouTube of some more of a stream
you want to be doing
that encoding in real-time.
And VP8's a very good
real-time--
JEFF POSNICK: I was actually a
little confused when we were
talking before and you were
saying real-time.
So real-time does not mean
you're going to get the
encoding done as quick
as possible.
Sorry, it does mean that it's
going to be as quick as
possible, but it's not
necessarily as high a quality
as you might get with the best
setting or even the good.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah, right.
It's not--
JEFF POSNICK: It's for scenarios
where getting the
real-time transcoding done is
the most important thing.
JOHN LUTHER: Yes.
And that's why it's
called real-time,
it's not called live.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: That's the
other distinction.
A lot of people say, well,
that's the live mode.
Well, it's not really.
That's the one that will be
encoding stuff in real-time
even if you're writing it
to a disk for later.
But if you want to be encoding
stuff as it's happening
without having like a gigantic
buffer of gameplay that you
then have to do--
JEFF POSNICK: Ok, great.
JOHN LUTHER: So, yeah.
That's pretty much the
use case for it.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: So then this
command just scales.
There are some settings here
for setting the bit rate.
And then this bit rate
threshold here, BT.
This is essentially saying
because this is a variable,
bit rate and code, that
easier sections of--
if there's a lot of static areas
in the video, you don't
want to encode those again,
it's redundant.
You just carry them over
from frame to frame.
But in other harder sections
you want to throw
more bits at those.
This just says, OK, I don't want
you to ever go over twice
the target bit rate because you
don't want gigantic spikes
in the VBR.
JEFF POSNICK: Gotchya.
JOHN LUTHER: That's really
all that is.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: And it's
going to scale it.
I'm going to dedicate
four threads to
this, processor cores.
And we're going to do
this in two passes.
First pass.
And then this one below is
pretty much the same stuff.
I don't actually need
all these up front.
So the second pass is the
one that's actually
going to do the work.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: First pass really
runs through very fast.
It says, OK, get a handle on
what's going on here and
gather some statistics and look
for where there might be
redundancies just to get
a kind of overview.
And then the second pass is
where the actual real encoding
and compression is
going to happen.
JEFF POSNICK: Oh, that's
interesting.
I didn't realize
that that was--
You have two sets of double
ampersands there.
I don't know if that's going
to mess up your--
JOHN LUTHER: Oh, thank you.
Good eye, good eye.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
JOHN LUTHER: All right, so for
the SD case we'll just paste
that in there.
And this maybe to some people
looks very scary.
What is going on here, all
this command line stuff?
This FFmpeg instance--
this is a Mac.
I installed this from MacPorts
in five minutes.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: Sudo port install,
FFmpeg, and VP8'Ss in
there, WebM muxer's in there.
All that stuff just comes right
down, same for Linux.
Windows, a little
bit trickier.
I don't have as much experience
doing FFmpeg on Windows.
But for Mac and Linux
it's just a snap.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
And, again, this use case is for
people that maybe want to
run their own encoding from
the command line.
But if you're writing an
application there are bindings
and [INAUDIBLE]
say things that you don't use.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah, FFmpeg--
I mean, you could
do that with it.
It's more of a--
if you can run it on a server
from the command line, you
could batch these things.
But, yeah, you're right.
If you were developing more of
a lower level application you
might want to just take libvpx
library, the libvorbis
library, and then we have
another library for
the muxer, the WebM.
In some cases people aren't
muxing them, they're actually
keeping the stream separate.
JEFF POSNICK: Interesting.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah, that's
another whole other
discussion.
So that's done.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: And you can see
here, right here, this is just
a test video that was created.
The guys at Elemental, there
were a lot of these MPEG test
clips they recreated
them at 4K.
So that's it.
JEFF POSNICK: There you go.
I mean, it's a little
unfortunate that the end
result here is just--
it's like when you
see a TV screen--
JOHN LUTHER: Right.
JEFF POSNICK: --and the
commercial on TV it's like,
OK, well this doesn't really
tell you what the actual video
quality is as I'm watching
it on my TV.
So you're watching that as
part of a video stream.
JOHN LUTHER: It's hard
especially when I go to a lot
of shows and do give
presentations and it's on a
gigantic projector.
Yeah, people are like
OK, whatever.
And it's also like,
look it's done.
It's like, well, yeah
it made a video.
OK.
JEFF POSNICK: Yes.
But try it out yourself
I guess.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah, definitely
try it yourself.
Write to me or to us.
I can give you my settings.
There are some WebM
presets in FFmpeg.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: We don't have time
to go through that, but
that's also easy to do.
But I'm very lucky to do what
I do, because I get to mess
around with this stuff.
Who wouldn't want to watch
TV for a living?
Well, maybe I don't watch TV.
But to get to watch--
JEFF POSNICK: I watch video.
I always have an excuse to
watch YouTube videos.
JOHN LUTHER: That's true.
I'm testing.
JEFF POSNICK: I know exactly
how you feel.
I'm debugging.
JOHN LUTHER: Exactly.
JEFF POSNICK: Exactly.
So OK, cool.
So that's another use case
we've gone through.
Let's it say a completely
different use case.
I'm like a hardware
entertainment device
manufacturer and I want to make
sure my device has good
support for WebM, presumably
decoding, maybe encoding.
What are some resources
that are available?
JOHN LUTHER: Sure.
In most cases for something like
a consumer electronics,
that would be primarily a
decoding use case though, we
do have WebBPX ported to ARM.
So there's the software.
Like I said, it's an Android.
There's also now what I was
mentioning earlier about these
things taking time.
And we're just sort of coming
over the crest of this, but
we're now getting to, and we
worked really hard on this, is
having a lot of hardware
companies, people who make the
actual chips that go into
devices, put VP8 decoding on
those chips in hardware.
JEFF POSNICK: Great.
JOHN LUTHER: Having that stuff
burned in silicon is much more
efficient then software
just because
there's not as much overhead.
It uses far less battery
power for devices.
So it's cool.
I mean, we're now seeing VP8
silicon coming from Samsung,
Qualcomm, Broadcom.
A lot of these major
semiconductor makers are
rolling this stuff out.
We also as part of our project
have an actual hardware team
and their job is to design
these codecs in a sort of
middle tier language.
Verilog, RTL, these are very--
these are not the kind of things
you guys I hope maybe
don't have to deal with.
But these guys--
JEFF POSNICK: Right, join
us next week for Verilog
developer's log live.
JOHN LUTHER: For a Verilog--
it's kind of cool.
These guys are way
up in Finland,
like in northern Finland.
And they're like little wizards
up there doing all
this magic stuff.
I have no idea how it works.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
I think for software people,
the folks who deal with
hardware it's always just--
JOHN LUTHER: It's a
whole other world.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, you're
kind of blown away.
JOHN LUTHER: So if you are
somebody who said, well, I've
looked at the offerings--
and on our site there's a page
where we list all the--
JEFF POSNICK: [INAUDIBLE]
bring that up.
JOHN LUTHER: We can give
that link later.
I don't right away have it.
JEFF POSNICK: And it's
at webmproject.org.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah,
webmproject.org.
That's it right here
under hardware.
Also there's a Wiki page that
lists like all the chips now
that are shipping with VP8
in them and so forth.
So anyway, these guys take these
designs and if you were
somebody who wanted to make your
own chip with VP8 in it,
encoding or decoding, we would
license those designs to you.
And then you could go to an
ASIC manufacturer and make
your own chip.
And a lot of people have
done that and they're
listed on the site.
Some of the companies have
written their own
implementations, which, again,
that's fine with us.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: It's what the
license is all about.
So, yeah, if device people--
there's a whole ecosystem
for that that's
finally growing up.
And this is what we knew would
take time and we're happy that
it's all starting to
come together.
JEFF POSNICK: OK, awesome.
So I definitely do not want
you to reveal anything
confidential or anything you
should not be talking about,
but what kind of things are
you working on now in the
whole codec space?
What are some things that might
be in the pipeline that
we should look forward to?
JOHN LUTHER: Well, one of the
things that is different now
is when we were On2 we were a
proprietary company, we did
this stuff to sell.
Now, it's an open project,
everything we
do is in the open.
So VP9, which we've been working
on for a while and is
starting to come together and
we're seeing some pretty
amazing results.
That's all been done
in the open.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
JOHN LUTHER: I mean, in this
experimental branch that I
have talked about is where
starting from VP8--
and now we have more resources
with Google, more engineers to
put on this stuff.
They've put some pretty amazing
stuff into VP9.
I don't know how much people
want to know about things like
superblocks and macroblocks and
vector prediction and all
this kind of-- there's a
lot of very cool stuff.
JEFF POSNICK: Well, I'm
personally interested and I
happen to be here with
you right now.
So--
JOHN LUTHER: OK.
JEFF POSNICK: ---whatever
they [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN LUTHER: You guys just
hit mute for a minute.
JEFF POSNICK: No, so I guess
I'm always curious, like,
where are the areas that
we can still improve?
At this point after spending
decades, I know there are
people who've spent decades
looking at these thing, what
areas are right for
breakthroughs?
Is it just a question of like
throwing more hardware speed
at things and be able to do
things you couldn't do before,
or other algorithms?
JOHN LUTHER: More hardware
never hurts.
But having been in this while--
and you do hear it
from people, well, at this
point it's all just
incremental improvements.
Again, our kind of charter is to
sort of reject that kind of
thinking and do whatever,
wild stuff.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: There's a lot of
things that we want to do in
the future that do get away
from the more traditional
what's called a DCT-based
codec, you
know, discrete cosine.
That's sort of the core
of how it's done.
You know, we kind of challenge
ourselves to do the big
thinking about that stuff and
not just a couple percent
here, a couple percent there.
In VP9 we're seeing huge, huge
improvements over VP8.
I mean, it's a gigantic leap
forward in terms of the
efficiency of the codec and what
it's capable of doing.
And a lot of that has been
just hard research--
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: --and a lot of
very smart people, not me,
people a lot smarter than me
working on the code and the
algorithms.
JEFF POSNICK: OK, fair enough.
Cool.
All right, thank you.
So I'm just checking out real
quick the Google Moderator
link that we have set up.
Unfortunately we do not have any
questions right now from
the external audience.
JOHN LUTHER: Oh, come
on, you guys.
JEFF POSNICK: So hopefully I was
able to ask on everyone's
behalf all the questions that
people wanted to know.
JOHN LUTHER: And if there's
something they want to ask,
johnluther@webmproject.org or
jluther@google.com, either one
will get to me.
JEFF POSNICK: That's great.
JOHN LUTHER: We also
have WebM-discuss.
There's a list of the mailing
lists on our site
where people can--
there's one for apps, one
for codec development.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JOHN LUTHER: You can ask
questions there.
We're always looking for
contributions to the project,
code, documentation, whatever.
Advocacy, anything people want
to do, everybody's welcome.
JEFF POSNICK: Great.
Good to know.
All right.
So I think that is about it for
our interview with John.
I'm going put a quick plug at
the end of the show as we do
on every show that Google's
Developer Relations team is
hiring and
developers.google.com/jobs is
the place to go, if you are
interested in doing what I do
such as interviewing--
JOHN LUTHER: I would
want to do that.
JEFF POSNICK: --cool people on
top of all the other stuff
that Developer Relations does.
So check that out if
you're interested.
And I just really want to thank
John again, it's been an
awesome show.
JOHN LUTHER: Thank you.
No, I appreciate
the invitation.
It was great.
JEFF POSNICK: Very cool.
OK.
JOHN LUTHER: Thanks everybody.
JEFF POSNICK: Bye everybody.